listen up [ __ ] that's my new neighbor
what is his name
captain funtastic that's what I've been
calling him such a nice day for a jog
[Music]
what my ass isn't a glutinous skirt
given the current climate it feels
inappropriate for me to comment on your
Bob tight as a snare drum you could
bounce a quarter off that thing screw
him today's Monday I'm making a partner
baby headline news somebody in this room
is about to be some worldwide sports
management snow its partner the sockets
oh [ __ ] your mom ad agency exec oh no
it's my brother said you're gonna [ __ ]
your brothers well they say that I don't
connect with men I hired a psychic
Facebook I can help you why don't we
have some tea
this smells like it hurts oh that's just
jasmine tea if you don't count the weed
and the peyote okay
[Music]
I feel weird after last night yeah
that's what happens when tequila meets
desperation stop doing are you reading
my mind because if you can hear my inner
thoughts I am super
does he mess me up did you [ __ ] yourself
no no no no no I have psychic powers you
can hear what I'm thinking right now not
you just me you know you could use this
to your advantage
right I'm bluffing these false pretzels
are delicious I'm gonna freeze my sperm
ahead baby ice cubes
[Music]
this shot look at you pressing all the
ladies
whatever why would I waste a second
owner when I got you standing right in
front of me why are her eyes always
closing ugly damn eyes open but she look
crazy as hell
[Music]
who are you I hope it's okay I borrowed
your mask
welcome to Wakanda close your mouth
don't breathe don't say
[Music]
you